what up guys this is the first time I'm
really putting all my new aftermarket
parts to use and it makes me crazy happy
so as you guys know
um we just sold our house but we have a
crazy timeline because the new buyers
are moving in from Texas which means we
have to be out of our house and I think
a week and a half so we have a lot of
packing to do we also have a kid that's
about to start school so Grandma is nice
enough to come and move in with us to
help us move and watch taika while we go
and rapidly like get our life together
so she is going to be moving in with us
for a few weeks so we have to pack a ton
of stuff and let me show you how
convenient
this bad boy is
all right check it out this thing is
packed to the brim look at that
we have all of type of stuffed animals
over there got a ton of stuff here dirty
laundry over here we were living here
pretty much for a whole month straight
so we moved all of our Necessities here
like protein blenders groceries Like You
Name It We had all kinds of stuff in
here and we also got Grandma stuff so I
have this whole part packed and then
back here
we also have our
forgot to lock the unlock the car
there you go
back here we have like our duffel bags
and then we got Grandma's luggage and
stuff we got a little space right here
so I have our snacks in here and these
drawers are packed to the brim too
um I brought all my weapons over here
because I've been shooting them for a
while like almost a few years and I
haven't cleaned them and that's not good
so I brought it over to gun effects the
city of Industry shot us to them they
have this really cool like ultrasound
cleaner I think it's ultrasound
where they put it in this bath solution
and they send this like sound wave
through and it just goes and you see all
the gun powder just boom just fall off
like the the weapons
so my back is entirely packed we also
didn't want to waste any of the
groceries so we packed two small coolers
full of groceries of course we got
taika's Legos
and we got enough space
for Grandma
enough space for taika enough space for
Mama
and it makes me so happy because as you
guys know this is the whole reason why I
bought this truck is to be our family
adventure vehicle so whether it's like
big road trips small road trips anytime
you get the whole family together that
makes me so happy so we have a ton of
space still
um probably our personal like carry-on
stuff we'll probably like put it right
here but my bear has enough space
to still sleep and lay down because it
is a four hour drive and if you're not
driving you get sleepy so I wanted to
make sure that we didn't pack too much
there and also have enough leg room for
Tyga's little danglers
so yeah everything is looking good
closing it back up
and uh we're gonna get on the road soon
okay so papa bear just came inside gave
me the camera and said he wants to get
my reaction don't know what he's trying
to show me but he says let's go outside
all right
I don't get what I'm supposed to react
to look I put all the luggage on top
I don't get it but why is that like what
do you mean have you never done that no
never so like I've always used the
inside of it right the inside is packed
look it's packed my homies don't know
how to act we in the back VIPs in the in
the back you know with the stack of
numbers and I was like oh cool where do
I put the rest of the stuff and it's so
cool that this thing is also a flatbed
so it could actually hold my weight
see that so I strapped all the luggage
up here because most luggage is also
weatherproof so
good job
so I don't think he wanted my reaction I
think he just wanted
I don't know what you wanted but yay
what's the natural reaction to
that's it yeah good job baby are you
sure it's gonna hold that looks a little
suss I already knew you're gonna say
some [ __ ] like that so don't worry
yeah that's what I even like that looks
hella sucks it's like doubled it
a double stranded triple stranded
quadruple stranded in okay so now we
have to make a bet
to see if our luggage is gonna make it
back because it looks like if one bump
one big bump all this shit's flying the
[ __ ] off how many bumps are on the 15.
well we're gonna find out will our
luggage make it back safely
that's gonna be fun
all right just gassed up ready to go on
this CUNY little road trip and I Gotta
Give It Up to taika look at this guy he
had a little bloody nose and I was like
oh no you got bloody nose and I was
gonna help him and then what did you say
monkey
that's crazy how did you learn how to do
that
oh you always do you been doing it
oh baby baby I don't know what's I'm not
supposed to show or not oh for likewise
excuse me but yeah so right now what is
it the Mega Millions yeah the Mega
Millions I think the jackpot is eight
hundred and thirty million dollars
and grandma got the good luck so
hopefully if we win something and then
just smacking my head
a minion yeah
look how Kenny's little car is we got
Mama we've got his kidney stuff we got
Mickey Mouse we got CUNY Grandma we've
got CUNY monkey Cheeto it's a party in
here road trip time
oh it's like never mind you know what I
thought that car was what
you know those 80s cups
oh with the uh the turquoise
you know I've seen people wear t-shirts
of that yeah and it looks like the soda
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's pretty
cool you know I just wanted to shout out
my boy taika in the back
such a freaking good traveler like he's
done this route so much now like he's so
good and he just plays this cute little
games in the back he's not fussy
whatsoever I've been trying to keep my
hands on the steering wheel you know the
couple times where I drove like like
this like you'll throw up yes mister
even when we went to like
to like Hawaii
he has this little backpack his luggage
and he just gets with the program you go
from the airplane it's time to get
luggage and we go grab a luggage and now
it's gonna get on the shuttle and not
once does he complaining he sticks with
the group and he keeps a watchful eye
and he got eyes on the back of his head
to make sure we all stick together and I
I think it honestly all of it has to do
with his mama doing a really good job of
training him
thanks dude because you're welcome dude
oh that's ugly
that's just my face
hey Marsha did a better job making her
good job Mom
just got to Barstow and it seems like
it's a family Tradition now that
whenever we travel with our parents we
gotta stop by
the Black Bear Diner
because uh most of the food on that side
of the freeway over there so when you go
over the freeway that goes over the 15
on that side it's mainly like fast food
but you can have like almost every
option you got like Del Taco in and out
Raising Canes Arby's Burger King
McDonald's Starbucks
Panera Bread like literally anything you
name it and then we wanted a more of a
sit-down environment especially when
we're traveling with
um you know elderly people so we like to
come on this side
the Black Bear Diner and we got monkey
Mama monkey dude and then we got CUNY
monkey Grandma over there
and stop it
it's just so funny and then damn this
truck looking kind of fly
clean I love the way a truck looks man
look at that
still got to get that part fixed though
freaking chill I can't believe Joe
smashed my truck into his truck that's
like the worst accident ever
hey who's this strong young man
whoa you are strong hoodies oh my
goodness babe you see those freaking
pies oh I've never salivated so hard in
my life
I want the bread pudding oh man I can't
wait till this diet's over
just another month that's so true that's
fast yeah five weeks that's nothing
that's a long time since we kept our
luggage on top of the truck on the
flatbed we asked to be able to sit
window seat right next to it so that we
can keep it tactically observant and
intelligent and that's why even I even
picked that uh parking space right here
because I'm gonna park anywhere I'm
gonna park over here or all the way over
there but I was like you know what
to be smart I'm a back into where I saw
that there was empty spaces like I saw a
bunch of empty spaces here so we back
into here now I can stay right here and
keep the watchful eye hey monkey when
you see a bad guy try to steal one of
our backs you gotta let me know okay
and they're gonna run out and get them
yeah I know I will get this and then
break the glass
ES
ouch
exactly
this kid's nuts and that oh dude all
right I gotta tell you guys the story
about I gotta move away from him because
it's so cute but I don't want him to do
it again so yesterday
uh we were sitting next to each other
and we're watching Oceans 13 right and
then uh it's very rare that he is able
to just watch like an adult movie with
me he needs like all the crazy animation
or whatever and uh he was sitting next
to me and then the characters in the
movie said some bad words and uh I
didn't pay attention because I'm an
adult right so they'll just go through
my ears tactical was like hey Papa can I
say it one time and I was like say what
one time and he goes mother [ __ ] I
don't see that I'm just gonna say one
time to say one time this kid has so
much personality it's nuts what are you
gonna do mister
let me know there's a bad guy you
guys
excuse me
there there there there or there so oh
okay my turn so I'm gonna be an X
so the way to win you have to get three
O's in a line okay so you have to get
three O's here or three O's here
I can that's what you want to do you
want to beat each other okay so I'm
gonna go X here
good job okay yeah
let's go now okay look I'm gonna have
two so now you want to block me block me
block me
there you go okay
no no no no look look you got two we win
you win Bingo you put a line you say I
win
okay cool which one are you you said
right all right so I think I found a
hidden talent okay this is incredible
look
okay all right okay and it keeps going
the concentration on his face
he's a little drunk
you did it again
you are amazing young man how did you
know how to do that
it's like because he I just saw a big
dummy yeah
you might be a genius
no no no you might be an undercover
genius no and now you want to put the
crayon in the drink he's definitely
you know what's pretty cool about Black
Bear Diner they actually have fat free
Italian dressing so that's what I got on
the side with my steak and although they
have a lot of really delicious things
one other thing that's really cool
is um they have their nutrition facts
online so if you're on a diet it can
help out see check it out yeah Hungry
Bear breakfast 71 grams of fat so
obviously I did not eat that but yeah
you can scroll through they got
breakfast lunch dinner
um we opted for the New York steak it
has almost 70 grams of protein with only
19 grams of fat so that's a pretty good
like protein fat ratio and it would have
to be really good and not eat any of the
yummy stuff so we just got a side of
green beans I did want a baked potato
but they don't serve those until after
four so that's something to keep in mind
wow you're crushing it not because I
want to just try to stay full huh yeah
yeah that's Mickey Mouse yeah it looks
just like you dude eat it
here we go I got the 10 ounce New York
steak came out look pretty good yeah not
bad got some veggies I opted for the
green beans definitely cannot be eating
the bacon and they topped off these
delicious onion rings oh my goodness
gotta put these over here
I should have got that
you're green beans oh really they're
good
oh yeah because I want to eat broccoli
it makes me fart for some reason so I
don't want to be farting on the car all
day good call
so this isn't something you see every
day driving to Vegas and it's raining
look at that
and it's a hundred and three degrees
and we also got Luggage in the back but
most of our luggage is waterproof see if
you can see it uh no oh wait that's it
that was it it was just that little
crazy just went
like Jesus was taking the leak or
something and he's done yeah
now it's dry it's so hot your windshield
you can't even catch it but yeah the
water drops on your windshield are now
dry like
all the water evaporated immediately
well all right wait are we in Vegas in
California right now we are still in
California okay because you got to keep
going until you pass state line and you
know it's state line because the minute
you pass it oh right there's the casino
there's a lot my mom knows about that
because the last change baby baby what
is the law
you get to have fun on one side oh got
it got it got it got it oh no no no no
oh you see some water droplets there
all right looks like I
won the bet in your face that's a good
job look at that look at that stayed on
the whole time huh good job
told you good job now you gotta trust me
from now on okay I'll never trust you
never trust me your life so many goddamn
times when I don't know all the time we
were like you're right that's true thank
you
made it home and put all the stuff away
already
so the house looks just as clean as we
left it oh my goodness what's going on
this guy bum rushed me
we are look at that my brother got all
the packing materials ready to go Takis
does a whole thing of toys this guy got
more toys than anyone in the world I
swear to God look at this a whole bag of
this is more toys that's more that's
more toys than I ever had my whole life
of course course your life is like no
one else's you
your country they probably have more
toys honestly they probably do
this guys it's just Pikachu's all the
toys he wants
okay let's go monkey let's go get dinner
yeah what do you got in a little pail
over there dude
you got a whole collection of McDonald's
toys
that's CUNY
do something
what are you gonna do a little trick
it's kind of hard let me see
whoa hey that's a cool trick dude
what is
about to do something really unusual
which is picked up some McDonald's oh
yeah
awesome
so um I'm just kidding I'm gonna do
something really unusual
we'll just pick up McDonald's before we
get sushi
and I typically wouldn't do this but I
did promise tuck that during lunch
promise is a promise that
um we were gonna go to McDonald's for
dinner
and I know like with my upbringing it's
like not all the kids can eat whatever
the hell the parents eat right same but
that's why I also never trusted my
parents because they never stuck to the
word yeah so I want to do now yeah so I
want to build trust with taika so if I
say I'm gonna do something I'm gonna do
it and earlier I actually sat in the
living room I'm gonna hit daika remember
taika as a hey tiger are you okay with
eating udon
and then you said what'd you say he said
no you want McDonald's right
now
okay
so I want him so I want to feel trust
with them and if that's what I said
we're gonna get for them tonight even
though we had our own change of plans
we're gonna get that for him to build
trust this little monkey dude
so we're gonna be bringing McDonald's to
a sushi restaurants
we're sure gonna kick us out hello
no you want a hamburger or chicken
nuggets
hi can I get a hamburger Happy Meal do
you know what the apples are extra fries
uh Apples please
the orange soda oh yeah
um
thank you thank you okay
how do you beat less than five bucks
like no wonder they make
junk food's so affordable and so goddamn
delicious
[Music]
and get you a Coca-Cola because it's
late and then Coca-Cola has a caffeine
you're gonna go crazy easy exactly
such trash
going to a business with outside food so
we're just gonna try to camouflage it
this way I feel so bad
oh my God are you serious we'll see what
happens let's see what happens come on
he looks happy
look at this sneaky little guy eating
his McDonald's try not to go together
give it away oh my God
oh my God
hey but you know what a family that's
sneaky together
ketchup
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yeah here we go
oh
oh my God
thank you
that's my favorite part Brown
now look at what we ordered for Grandma
oh my God
in Vegas honestly has one of the best to
show you Ramen that I've ever tried and
I don't know like yeah it's really good
and it's not like a
um like super like Gourmet or like
Michelin star Chef's way but a very
home-cooked way you know when you eat it
it just hits you in the soul so like I
really love their Ramen here like you
you eat and it just feels like like some
Japanese grandma made it
Grandma
Grandma's hamburgers
all right coming right up the first
order of sushi abacore
I don't think it needs any soy sauce it
already looks like it's a has a sauce on
it but that's it I do what I want
good
yeah
it's a little diet tip
Sushi is awesome if you need low fats
because it's just straight up a big old
piece of lean protein on some carb very
little fat and
um I got distracted because I was like
where's this little dude going I think
he wants his little secret soda that's
why
but yeah so which is why we're here to
get some sushi it's one of the only
things that I can eat out with again
we'll eat like three things when I'm on
a diet eat out which is one it's sushi
two is shabu-shabu with a lean cut of
meat three is also a pho but only the
rare steak I can't have the rib eye or
the flank or anything like that those
are the only three things that hit my
macros but Sushi looks whoa someone
already ate the other two that was fast
nobody gets more steps in than this guy
look at this constantly
it's like look at me watch I got in
quite a few steps today and my goal is
always to hit 10 000 every single day to
keep up with my weight loss goals I had
13
000.
but I'd move a fraction of what this guy
does
this is non-stop this guy's crazy
are you kidding me
what are these guys up to
look here yep look safe to me
he's so happy
[Applause]
so since grandma is here
type of course isn't gonna stay in his
room he's gonna be sleeping with Grandma
so he's just bringing all kinds of fun
stuff to bring into Grandma's room so we
had my dad move upstairs into that room
so that grandma could stay in the guest
room down here and of course instead of
bringing it down the normal way
he has to drop it
okay excuse me
wow it's strong
hey Grandma I'm Gonna Leave This For You
excuse me
here so when you put on your shoes
and when tiger runs out he can smash
into it
just went to sleep with Grandma
after me and techa watch blade because
that's our nightly routine here and uh
we wanted to keep up with tradition and
I don't know what it is but he loves
like crazy scary stuff and with action
so we just watched it on the couch
it's not on her bed usually watches on
our bed and then goes to his room but
he's gonna sleep with Grandma tonight
so I watched that and now I'm gonna get
ready to go to bed so we'll see you guys
what in the easy
we'll see you guys tomorrow good night